Jeff is with us to start off this hour
in Sacramento
hi Jeff how are you doing good how are
you sir better than I deserve what's up
well we are in the process of downsizing
making the decision to downsize from
where when we moved up here by the year
ago from Los Angeles my wife got a job
offer up here and it's obviously cheaper
living up your end but we ended up
taking a house that was more expensive
than maybe was good for us in terms of
rent and so my wife is doing pretty
uneasy about downsizing because we
wanted to give her children a really
nice place to live and she wanted to
find out any recommended things for her
to read or look at or something to make
her feel better about the decision we're
making because we're going to be cutting
our payments probably by 2/3 of what
we're currently paying
okay well that's wonderful um the
neighborhood's not unsafe that you're
moving - no no it's actually a good
neighborhood okay so it's just the the
size of the house and the the attributes
of the house that that are going to be
downsized yeah it's moving from like
clean almost 2,800 square feet really
900 feet and how many children - okay
and and how long do you anticipate
living in that property umm-hmm goal is
no more than three years we want to be
able to buy a property outright and do
you have a mathematical plan to get
there in three years
yes you do okay all right well I mean
you can walk through broken glass or
poop as long as you're looking past it
right yes okay and so what I'm doing is
I'm saying we're going to live like no
one else so that later we can live like
no one else and give like no one else
we're paying a price here with our
family this is a two-year a three year
adventure that this family is going on
and and why are we doing it we're doing
it for the family
correct it's not like when we're doing
it so we can because you know because
somebody's got a drug habit we're doing
it because this is what's good long-term
for your kids and I think that's what
she's struggling with because she thinks
that part of her feels that this this
place is also for the family something
for the children yeah but the point is
that that I mean most of us that are
older realized and even some that aren't
older realized that and she does too if
she just thinks about it that home the
quality of your household the quality of
your home life is not based on square
footage correct I mean to a reasonable
degree you know and I grew up in a
thousand square foot house and there
were two kids you know we had a full
basement we finished the basement out
later and I guess that got it up or
partial part of the basement so that
probably got it up to maybe 1,500 feet
or something like that but um you know
it was and I didn't die for my thing
anything about it I still don't think
anything about it only it's that bad a
deal do I want to live there now no but
I paid a price to not have to live there
so you know your all's attitudes towards
each other the way you face into the
future the lessons your teaching your
kids about why you're doing this and how
you're doing this are a whole lot more
important to quote home life than
square-root than bricks and mortar are
absolutely the quality of your marriage
the quality of your vision for your
family and your vision for your family's
future and communicating that to the
kids and kids here's what we're doing
we're taking a step back and doing
something painful to get a great gain
and we actually did this several years
ago when we went broke we had a home in
one part of Nashville that we didn't
think the public schools there were okay
so we put our kids in a private school
when they entered kindergarten
very expensive and is on the side of
tenants we're driving back and forth and
writing these big checks
well we decide finally we're going to
sell that and we move
into this rental house for two years now
I've up to that point I had owned 150
houses and now I'm a renter you talk
about a step down that was a step down
yeah we've kind of went through some
similar a few years back and so Sharon
was like she hated that rental house you
know like your wife is is you know not
liking the feel of this situation but
insuring to this day will tell you she
can tell you the color of the kitchen
she didn't like it you know but we just
knew it we were camping it was temporary
we knew we were going to be there about
two years and we moved into a school
district that we could put the kids
right into the public school save that
money we didn't drive across town saved
got our life back and we rented for two
years and piled up money and we're able
to you know buy a hole like you're doing
and so it but it I don't you know do I
want to do that no I don't want to do
that do I want the result yes did I want
to get up at 5 a.m. and spend 45 minutes
on the FX this morning no I didn't want
to do that but I eat too much so I need
to do that so you know I mean there's
price to be paid to win and and the
thing is your children are not going to
suffer nearly as much as she's going to
suffer yeah I told her the same thing
they don't give a rip yeah they think
it's a camping trip how old are they 7
and 11 all their part is perfect teach
them a life lesson here this is this is
a thing that could reshape their whole
lives if you talk about it in a positive
light I'm excited about it for you guys
um you know but you can't you don't want
to communicate to your children that the
quality of their relationships the
quality of their life is based on square
footage you know our in other words the
purchase of an item you don't want to
communicate that value to your children
instead you want to communicate to them
and we pay a price to win and this is a
great physical opportunity to do that
hold on I'm going to send you a copy of
the book that Rachel my daughter and I
did together called smart money smart
kids there's a great chapter in there on
teaching your kids contentment and I
think it applies to this situation I
think you'll enjoy it
hold on I'll have Kelly pick up we'll
give it to you I'm excited for you guys
I think this is going to work out great
for you
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you are not a victim you're not
a victim of big corporations you're not
a victim of Wall Street you're not a
victim of capitalism you're not a victim
of wealth inequality you're not a victim
of racism you're not a victim